amas nella vita reale
Sì Conoscete tutti le regole del gioco
sìì eh io no Ok non ti preoccupare
adesso te lo spiego Ogni giocatore ha il
suo colore unico e collaborando con gli
altri dovrà portare a termine degli
obiettivi chiamati T Ma attenzione fra
di noi c'è un impostore che può
eliminare gli altri quindi se vedete
qualcosa di strano o sospetto dovrete
premere subito il pulsante dell'
Emergency meeting così ci riuniremo
tutti qui per capire insieme cosa è
successo e votare per eliminare
l'impostore tutto
chiaro no perfetto
[Musica]
iniziamo
Ok sono nella stanza giusta Questa è la
mia Task devo riparare il sistema di
ventilazione proprio quello
lì Sì ok ma come
faccio Vabbè dai diamo un'occhiata in
giro devo cercare qualcosa di elettrico
interruttore una leva un qualcosa che
possa aggiustarlo M ma dove sarà Ciao
nero Ciao arancione che ci fai qua sto
cercando di riparare con la ventola Ah
il sistema di ventilazione Sai l'ho
riparato 1le volte io Ma sì eh sì adesso
lo riparo ti faccio vedere come fa No no
sono arrivato prima io e vabbè che
c'entra Non lo so non lo sai fare io
almeno Sì ci sto riuscendo Ma io ti
faccio vedere come si fa la faccio io la
t no sono arrivato prima io ma se non
sai nemmeno da dove iniziare allora dimm
tu arancione che sei così tanto
intelligente Tanto per iniziare ci vuole
il
telecomando Eccolo Eh ma che stai
facendo serve a me no io l'ho fatta un
sacco di volte questa Eh vabbè serve a
me va bene io farò qualcos'altro allora
Divertiti lo
farò ma non funziona manco
questo mancano le batterie adesso devo
mettermi a
cercarle siete qui
[Musica]
Uh Eccole
qui Come si
mette ciaè vero No questa è la mia Task
ce l'ho quasi fatta manca
pochissimo
[Musica]
ok fatto fuori il primo sono proprio
brava a fare
l'impostore Sento dei passi devo
nascondermi altrimenti mi scopriranno
Uffa però nero dai non so che cosa fare
Fatti aiutare con l'impianto di ventil
nero
nero oh no nero è stato eliminato
dall'imposta
Eva che è successo chi ci ha
teletrasportati qui sono stato io a
teletrasportarmi qui ho premuto il
pulsante di emergenza perché ho trovato
il corpo di
nero ma chi può essere stato Oh no la
prima vittima non lo so Io ho visto solo
il corpo di nero Lì stava facendo la
tasca della
ventilazione Aspetta ma chi ci dice che
non sia stato tu io Io ho solo trovato
il corpo po' di nero è il momento di
votare votiamo Eh ma
aspetta Io non sono stato ma secondo me
sei stato tu quello che trova il corpo
molto spesso è quello che l'ha ucciso
Non è vero assolutamente non posso
essere stata io ok siccome non abbiamo
abbastanza prove questa volta skippi
[Musica]
ok La nostra tasca è trovare libro
speciale Guarda c'è una libreria enorme
qua iniziamo a cercare presto
ok Questo
no vediamo forse
questo il gatto nero non credo che sia
questo vediamo
questo
Wow non credo che sia nemmeno questo e
questo nemmeno Insomma
medusa
no Viola ho una domanda Come facciamo a
capire qual è il libro speciale Beh
immagino che visto che è speciale Una
volta che lo troveremo lo
capiremo Ciao rosso Ciao Viola Che cosa
fate Qui stiamo cercando di completare
la nostra tasca e cioè trovare il libro
speciale Uh un libro speciale posso
aiutarvi ok Sì certo sì oh che bello
Allora troviamo questo libro speciale
Ma
dov'è
ma può essere che il libro che stiamo
cercando è il tuo libro Beh in effetti
il mio nuovo libro è davvero un libro
speciale la città stregata voi ce
l'avete è il mio nuovo libro uscito da
pochissimo che trovate ora onl e in
libreria Anche qua c'è un mistero da
risolvere in cui dovete scoprire il
colpevole Quindi se ancora non ce
l'avete andassi subito a prenderlo e se
volete Mandatemi una foto con il libro
su Instagram e io Vi
saluterò Task
completato
eh Ma l'hai l'hai eliminata sei stato tu
non io no non sono stato io Sei stata tu
io e invece no sei stato tu e ora
Emergency
meeting Chi ha chiamato il meeting ho
chiamato io l'emergency meeting perché
rosso è stata eliminata e ho anche visto
chi è stato e chi è stato bianco bianco
sì no no non è vero Sì tu non me la
racconti giusta sì per me sei stato tu
bianco Ma c'ero an ch'io in quella
stanza e non l'ho fatto io fatto L'ha
fatto Viola l'ha fatto Viola quindi
c'erano tutti e due nella stessa stanza
per me è stato bianco io voto bianco
ovviamente voto anche io bianco perché
due votano bianco anche io voto
[Musica]
bianco anche tu qua tra i
vincitori Ma noi siamo i fantasmi siamo
quelli che hanno
perso
[Musica]
bianco non era l'impostore e sai che
cosa vuol dire questo che l'impostore
sei tu sì no Semmai vuol dire che è uno
di voi due l'impostore Io non sono
l'impostore Anzi vado a fare le mie Task
e non provare a seguirmi non mi
interessa seguirti Anch'io vado a fare
le mie
Task Ok la mia Task è copiare i dati di
questa tessera penso che sarà molto
rapida questa
task
60 secondi per copiare dei
[Musica]
dati devo ripristinare la corrente e
questo è il pannello
elettrico eh questa Ciao arancione rosa
che cosa ci fai qui ho finito la mia
tasca e ho pensato di aiutarti Ah ma che
gentile Ah no no no no Tu c % di
probabilità che tu sei l'impostore Hai
ragione arancione ma non sono io te lo
posso giurare se
vuoi allora se la metti così ok va
bene Visto che sei così gentile potresti
passarmi quel cacciavite là sotto così
finisco la mia Task Sì certo te lo
prendo
[Musica]
io oh no devo chiamare subito
l'emergency meeting
l'ho chiamato io l'emergency meeting
Allora ti devo spiegare un sacco di cose
praticamente Stavo stavo facendo la
tasca dell'Elettricità a un certo punto
è arrivata rosa e rosa mi stava dicendo
che mi voleva aiutare Però praticamente
lei mi ha offerto aiuto ma in realtà
quando si è girata ho visto che c'aveva
una cosa dietro e quindi è lei
l'impostore è lei l'impostore Ma cosa
stai dicendo Viola non crederci Cioè
solo perché hai visto che aveva una cosa
dietro e l'impostore Sì è lei
l'impostore Ma cosa stai dicendo non
sono io e se fossi invece tu e stai
cercando di convincermi in modo che se
elimini amorosa poi rimango sola con te
mi elimini no non farei mai una cosa del
genere ma ti sto dicendo S arancione sei
tu Viola Ti ricordi la prima vittima
nero è stato vitale a chiamare
l'emergency
meeting Ma è vero Ho chiamato
l'emergency meeting perché l'ho trovato
lì perché sei stato tu no non sono stato
io davvero in effetti è vero quello che
dice Rosa tu eri assieme a nero per
aiutarlo a fare una Task e poi guarda
caso nero è stato eliminato e hai
chiamato l'emergency meeting ma non sono
stato io cioè nel senso Sì ho chiamato
l'emergency meeting Ma perché ho visto
nero per terra che era stato eliminato
ma non sono stato io invece no potresti
averlo eliminato tu quindi tu sei molto
sospetto io voto te no no no no no
aspetta aspetta aspetta Mi è venuta in
mente una cosa quando ho chiamato
l'emergency meeting Rosa aveva un'ascia
nascosta dietro la schiena Prova a
vedere se ce l'ha ancora
lì Rosa
girati Va bene allora vi eliminerò
[Musica]
io Ah sì ce l'abbiamo fatta era lei
l'impostore ratore abbiamo V questa
Challenge poi cliccate mi piace qua
sotto e ora vi lasciamo qua quro
casellini su cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quello
che preferite e buona visione
Ciao